我跟你说啊，
软话可以随时说，
钱可不能给啊，
谁敢动到我的实际的利益，
谁敢动到我的钱袋，
做谁就是我的仇人，
听明白没有，
现在我的情况就是感觉我老公在外面应该是有人了，
因为我老公他挣钱也比较能淡的，
他一年可以挣100来个，
我呢也就是30来个一年，
那现在就是长期出差在外面，
有时候就是变化呀什么的，
有一两天就不联系，
你跟他联系的时候就明显就感觉到他心情不是很好，
但是我也理解他的压力是很大，
但是就是说我们结婚也20多年了嘛，
我小孩现在大学也毕业了，
就是一个小孩，
我现在就是站在我这个现在的角度嘛，
我就觉得是万一就说你要是想分开呢，
那毕竟是这么多年了，
我就是85%这个小朋孩，
但是我也想了呢，
他的工作上我也帮不了他忙，
所以我就觉得吧，
你能找到能帮助你的，
那到时候你就会给我说的，
我就也没管他，
他这家庭也很负责任，
他之前挣的钱就是买车呀，
买房呀，
对么这些这家庭也挺好的，
他最不好的就是在哪里呢？
就是在同事啊，
我们在同事的面前，
他选择。
就是我一个领导吧，
比如说他主动跟一个女生夹菜，
但是我觉得是他是对这个女生有一点那个这候一个想法，
感觉让我很不舒服了，
就是一大桌人嘛，
就是我们比较团结的时候，
你看这样说的话，
就等于是在给别人有信号，
然后又在把你红面没有好好沟通过，
但是彼此都沟通不下来，
现在只要一提他都会要听到你说这个事儿呢，
我觉得我建议你去看朱元璋和马皇后，
我建议你去学一下马皇后，
我要是你的话啊，
我看过，
对，
我要是你的话啊，
他给别的姑娘夹菜对不对，
我就给他的左右手的那些男的啊主管我给他们夹菜，
我给他们安顿好，
我给这兄弟们安顿好，
我不要那么小气，
他愿意给谁夹菜是他的事儿啊，
就是我给兄弟们都安顿好，
给这些公司里面这些元老都安顿好，
关系都处好啊，
我不嫉妒，
我啊，
不小气，
你愿意给谁夹菜，
你给谁夹菜，
我就处好我自己的这帮哥们儿，
处好我自己的这帮嫡系兄弟啊，
就这意思啊，
让兄弟们觉得嫂子人挺好的，
嫂子人不错，
人又大方，
就是稳固自己的千古地位，
情情爱爱的事儿看淡一点，
他给谁夹菜他跟谁要看淡一点啊，
咱们到这个年纪了，
孩子都已经大学毕业了，
要的是什么？
要的是江湖地位，
要的是财产权利，
要的是什么？
要的是我的孩子能继承多。
好东西，
对不对？
我很欣赏您的，
就是这一点，
我心里怎么想我都敢说，
但是现在那个女的啊，
之前那个女的对他没有什么想法，
但是现在那个女的对他有想法，
我跟你说有想法，
你老公啊，
他分手的时候，
他也得权衡利弊，
他得想一想，
我跟我现在这个老婆分手，
我得割多大一块肉，
我得割多少钱出去，
他才能跟我分，
我割了这块肉了之后，
我还剩多少，
然后我得想想我的江湖影响利，
我跟现在这个女的在一起的话，
她得想从我身上搞多少钱，
我付出这个成本代价的话，
划不划算，
我到底是划算还是找她划算？
我跟你说，
男的到这个年纪了，
他肯定会算这个账啊，
我是再多找几个划算，
还是就在这一个坑里划算，
他都会算这个账，
只要你不闹他，
只要你不去想他的面子，
只要你不去怎么怎么地的天天追着他，
他自己会算账。
第一，
我跟原配离婚的话，
我得要付出多大的成本，
第二，
我到底是多几个多那个什么几个便宜，
还是说我跟这一个货我性价比高，
那就不会谈了，
一共三个店铺，
一个是在外省，
一个是在我老家，
所以另外老家那一个呢，
之前是160个左右，
但是现在在外省这个呢，
是120个，
就是说老爸跟我分开了，
老家那个他会给我的，
他买的时候我签上的名字，
另外一个你是签上的名字，
只有在外省，
这个是没有，
只花一个人。
但是这个住房的话，
两套的话是他的一套现在还在还房贷的，
估计还有60万左右，
但是另外一套的话就是我的，
你这那一套的话，
还完了就基本上就也装修好了，
做了两年了，
也就说现在就是您这头具体的问题是啥呀，
他赚的多，
但是我现在就是赚的少，
然后我是代下房，
假如说我现在要跟他分开，
假如他提出来要跟我分开的话，
我该怎么办，
很可怜，
如果他要跟你分开的话，
你说咱们都是少年夫妻老来伴，
不管怎么说的话，
咱们这些年咱们有了孩子，
孩子都已经毕业了，
我肯定是希望你身体好，
我肯定是希望你健康，
我肯定不会给你找麻烦，
咱也先别说那个分开的事儿，
对孩子影响也不好，
孩子以后要不管是要结婚啊，
要干嘛，
人家亲家一看咱俩就分开了，
对孩子也有不好的影响，
对吧，
你去体验，
我不拦着你，
这家一直都是你的家的后方，
咱以后孩子成家了，
咱还得给孩子张罗呢，
就这样，
意思就是说软话，
为孩子考虑，
反正我不影响你，
反正我也不会耽误你，
我那天我就说，
我说你老是这样子，
我说要是我现在是不管你啊，
我也不看你手机什么的，
要是你如果是当我发现了，
我就去那个，
让你去做几天再给你分，
然后他就没说话，
我现在。
就觉得吧，
心情稍微有一点低落，
就感觉到吧，
自己也比较闲，
他呢也比较辛苦，
他在外面出差就是忙工作的事儿，
然后我觉得我又帮不上他，
所以我就觉得现在就是不能是占下方的，
但是就像你说的，
只说软话，
不然我说软话我不给你添乱呀，
我给你守住家呀，
守住家里大后方啊，
我又跟那年轻小姑娘不一样，
我又不乱花钱，
我这钱都给你攒着呢，
咱俩死了还得埋一块儿呢，
咱孩子以后将来还得给我俩上香呢，
是不是？
我又不影响你，
我又不乱花钱，
我给你管好大后方，
我给你这老了生活安排的明明白白的就是少年夫妻老来伴，
不然的话你要找个年轻的，
你病了之后，
你是觉得他希望你死还是希望你活呀，
只有我这个原配才希望你好好的活着呀，
那年轻的是吧，
希望你早死，
早继承你的财产，
就这么说啊，
我们之前是一个公司，
现在就发了一个工资的话，
发的经济的话就是他只有180左右，
然后我呢，
我自己也存了有200来个，
因为之前买家里的一起开销就是8的8，
现在就是他想让我把我的积蓄给他再去创业，
就是那种感觉吧，
但是他没明说，
装傻不了，
我跟你说软话可以随时说，
钱可不能给啊，
谁敢动到我的实际的。
第一，
谁敢动到我的钱袋子，
谁就是我的仇人。
听明白没有？
软话可以说做小福低我可以想动我的钱袋子，
你算老几？
就这意思啊，
这样啊，
拜拜，
记住了吗？
所有的姐妹们啊，
软话可以，
我可以说一句箩筐装可怜我可以做小伏低我可以不影响你在外面怎么怎么的我可以，
谁敢来动我的钱袋子啊，
这是我的养老钱，
以后想帮衬我的孩子，
帮衬儿子儿媳妇儿，
这是我的底气，
谁敢动我的钱袋子，
就是我的仇人，
说最软的话，
给我办最狠的事儿，
门儿都没有，
想动我的钱，
记得点赞关注哦。